tu n pas le premier
poisson qui se meurt dans un beau
caldau la bouche ouverte le ventre en
l'air les yeux comme des bit de
lotau je ne suis pas le premier
ballon qui crève dans un ciel trop bleu
éclaté sous des cous d'épingles d'un
petit garçon aux yeux creux tu n'es pas
le premier chat noir qui frissne devant
ma porte et qu'elle en retrouve au matin
r des p comme feuille morte tu n'es pas
la première guitare ton les cordes ce
sont
brisé je ne suis pas le premier
garçon à qui tu dis c'est terminé
mais si ça peut te
consoler ça n'arrive pas seulement à
toi ce que je viens de te chanter
d'autres me l'ont dit
autrefis tu n'es pas le premier
mouton que les loups grill on
dévoré dans une forêt sans
abri par un hiver froid sans pitié tu
n'es pas le premier marin
abandonné dans
l'océan et Don les appels au secours
sanséantter par le fond tu n'es pas le
premier guignole qui rate son lev de
rideau et que le CRE F tard on voit
passer sur les
traitons tu n'es pas le premier
oiseau qui s'est asphyxier dans sa
classe
tu n'es pas le premier
roman dont je ne veux plus tourner les
pages mais si ça peut te
consoler ça n'arrive pas seulement à
toi ce que je viens de te
chanter d'autres me l'ont dit
autrefis tu n'es pas la première
guitare dont les cordes se sont
brisé je ne suis pas le premier G
à qui tu dis c'est
terminé mais si ça peut me consoler bon
n'arrive pas seulement qu'à
moi ce que tu viens de me
chanter d'utres me l'ont dire autre
[Musique]
fois